so when the trailer for legend of the
sea devils dropped i was uh busy
prepping for and then being in a
burlesque show so i was not up for doing
a reaction however i have now seen the
thing a couple of quick thoughts first
of all i love the sea devils i'm going
to be re-watching that original sea
devils
uh cereal from the classic arrow who uh
in the not-too-distant future uh and i
like that they're hinting that the
mercury is coming back like of all
things to take another crack at
absolutely the merka because it was
terrible last time i like this in
general they should revisit things that
there was nothing wrong with the concept
but just like it didn't work the
execution was off for whatever reason
that's the kind of stuff that's worth
bringing back and trying again because
you can do it better i'm a sucker for
pirates anyway so this thing in a lot of
ways is just
setting me up for hopefully really
enjoying it a lot of pieces are in place
that are inclining me towards liking
this and i really hope i do
we'll find out